und auch der highspeed chase alter usain
bolt zweimal bisschen bolt jagd sich
selbst über die map und jetzt schilder
sich sehr wohl herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute zu einer neuen
folge der hacker show endlich wieder
nachgefüllt einem ja und ja leute ich
bin momentan noch in der phase bis zum
15 juli heißt noch eine woche lang habe
ich noch eine hausarbeit für meine uni
und sicher momentan überhaupt kein leben
schreibt bis spät in die nacht an der
hausarbeit tagsüber nämlich ein videos
auf schneide bla bla bla bla bla
ja ich habe wie immer fünf clips
rausgesucht für euch fangen jetzt an mit
platz sommer von james rizzi verheißt
ein hacker in quake wars ein hacker in
kuwait seine kann es eventuell sein dass
jemand so ein bisschen connection
probleme hat hat er verhält sich gerade
mit einem bambusrohr aus dem garten im
internet verbunden ist das eventuell
möglich und der typ hier angeblich hexen
etwas wie hoch ist auch schon gestorben
aber wo ist jetzt ist die große frage
jan hof kleiner hostie taylor ho leute
die keine hockey ist es die horny das
ist nicht die hitze gestorben
da ist die hob das alter kommt euch das
mal an er blinkt durch die gegend what
the hell seht ihr das fakt dass ihr euch
wieso der ostafrikanische heck klein ist
der billigste qualität dann blinkt die
ganzen heermann backmann teleportiert
sich seht ihr das seht ihr wie dieser
typ sich bewegt also leute wenn ihr
heckt benutzt niemals in ostafrika klein
sonst geht das so bei euch aus der junge
ist ja nicht mehr zu retten er tut mir
leid guckt euch das an der backe alter
wgz bringt der kurz mal nicht okay und
er hat wen wundert's ein objekt blanc
aber der gelbe auch was als oder zwei
hecken in der runde ist sieht aus als er
kurz vor seinem internetanbieter
angerufen hätte seine leitung gefixed er
bringt nicht mehr so verrückt durch die
gegend jetzt noch eine klavier richtige
trap und des klinkers zurück
hat dieser mann das gkn i fucking series
sieht dieses movement das ist und das
ist nicht mehr normal leute wenn ich
drauf anlegen würde wenn ich mir ein
flyer installieren würde und bei der
tastatur eine maus nehmen wird und dem
fenster schmeißen würde
nachdem ich sie drei mal gegen die wand
gehauen habe ich würde nicht so ein muss
man hinkriegen er ist einfach nur
gestört
weiter gehts ladies gentlemen mit platz
habe ich hatte gesagt dass andere platz
eins sorry dafür ich muss ein bisschen
reinkommen in harrachov betrieb es geht
weiter mit platz vier und zwar von go
wie gummi gummi gummi hdf kino kino ja
backchecking abwassers sein könnte
fast immer erst mal spinnst ok alles
klar wir befinden uns auf dem ua auf
dieser einen warum web warum und wir
haben 35 punkte stein schwert und 24
chargers und brot effekte kann ich jetzt
erstmal nicht erkennt wenn es in dem
vier zeigt der kleine und ok 33 schläge
kassiert feuer sollte gleich daniel und
stickt überfielen sie das jetzt mit der
faust ins nichts hat er andere
jazzklassikern chefs problem
ok jetzt langsam wird zeitweilig zu
sterben an freund ok also so langsam was
also nochmal zu dem zeitpunkt hat der
andere bereits vier fünf sechs schläge
kassiert wurde einmal angezündet und
feuerzeug
jetzt sind er sich selbst noch mal an
kassiert noch mehr schläge 3 bestimmt
nochmal 456 ist alles kriz und und
stirbt nicht sondern tötet den
aufnehmenden mit monat mit der hand ok
alles klar dass hier doch ganz normal
aus den boxen einfach mit der hand das
ist alles kein ding der aufnehmende box
mit der hand das wort problem aber jetzt
also eigentlich hätte da schon sterben
müssen meiner meinung nach ja zum glück
nichts gefressen zauber angezündet alles
klar
jetzt wäre dreimal tod firma tut und
jetzt gilt er hat 971 im herzen
wahrscheinlich als ich meine leute
nämlich ein verschwörungstheoretiker
aber ich glaube dass es bei 971 im
herzen nicht ganz mit rechten dingen
zugehen könnte auch sein dass eine
beleuchtete tastatur hat ist ist es
nicht ausgeschlossen ich will es nicht
ausschließen
versteht mich nicht falsch aber es geht
vielleicht nicht alles mit rechten
dingen zu wenn der fucking 1000 herzen
hat
platz 3 heißt extremer kicker mit um
geld drehten kopf in der community
bombay und wir checken direkter passiert
uns ein geschickt hat okay ein ganz
normaler ganz normaler samstag und wird
in der lobby und ich das mit meinen
freunden kommt einfach dieser diese hier
ist dein kopf raus gesteckt und dann
bewegen sich voll viele viel zu schnell
in dieser leute was ist da los man als
wir alle hacken leute bitte seid mir
nicht das community hätten immer noch
ein ding ist fliesst aber ich finds gut
von ihm hat seinen kopf jetzt bisschen
aus den schultern rausgezogen
tatsächlich läuft aber ein bisschen rum
ihr volles kurz auf dem boden während er
hin und her sprintet wie ein gestörter
sonic auf crack voll wasser was erwartet
man sich davon
das ist wie so ein kugelschreiber auf
ein blatt papier wenn irgendwas
durchstreichen so ist sein buch exakt
ganz ehrlich leute kopf nicht zwischen
schultern zu haben sondern auf den
schotter zu haben das ist halt pohl das
will keiner
das hier ist das ist denn nun steht
allerdings der new shit sich auf der
stelle drehen ja alles in allem würde
ich sagen durchaus vernünftige
entscheidung in seinem leben in der
community zu hacken
wie immer müssen wir die leute die in
der community hätten das entwickelten
besten müssen die die die deutliche 1
ok jetzt so langsam
wir sind bei platz zwei gekommen da der
stand von crazy pvp und heißt hacker für
sk okay was geht
wir haben hier gerade ein hacker auf die
milliarde dollar also erst einmal auf
dem pferd und darum schild jemand in der
luft und greift ihn aus der luft mit dem
bogen an während er da oben einfach
schild keine katharina chapter oben
einfach spannend ein mich sieht momentan
nicht danach aus als hätte er irgendwie
lustiger herunterzukommen oder stairway
to heaven der kommt runter okay okay
und dann geht wieder hoch was das ist
spec täter keine ahnung irgendwas
brauchen das war der games aus wir
werden diesen fährt was einfach auch mal
durch die gegen friedberg und runter
hatte dieses movement gesehen gerade
innerhalb von einer sekunde so 100
blöcke gelaufen könnte durchaus ein
headset sein was wir gerade sehen würde
ich jetzt erstmal im moment nicht
ausschließen leute ja ok
mehr dolby surround möglich wie siehst
du bist gestorben das ist so eine sache
die ich nie verstehen werde leute wenn
man sich schon so den arsch ab hängt ja
ganz derbe gesprochen warum verliert man
nie so viele einsendungen von hackern
die einfach hacken bis zum gehtnichtmehr
herumschießen mit 1000 betten pro
sekunde bewegungsgeschwindigkeit oder
wie er von der luft schild verdient
einfach am ende
warum heckmann dann es ist herzlich zu
monat ganz normales wollen den gegner
später erfahre luft hat keinen bock
drauf ich sage so leute wer das headset
hat der kann es hätte auch nutzen so
system
platz eins heißt bob klammer auf hacker
börse steve kammer auf hacker plus lobby
back und stammt von p2p zu auch an dich
dankeschön für den einsendung just den
ersten platz gemacht unser heutigen
folge ok go maly sieht nach usd aus okay
da darf einfach den ersten hacker hat
den temporär usain bolt in dispatch es
los mit dem ok dass der hacker und der
war doch keine andere der auch nur
leicht seltsames hofmann hatte oder bob
der baumeister ist rasiert und jetzt
habe ich glaube ich zwei haken einander
diese eine der daneben schon gehackt mit
der einrüstung der anderen die rüstung
und der highspeed alter usain bolt
zweimal bisschen ball jagt sich selbst
über die map addiert wird viel speed und
jetzt auch aussteller sich und begeht
dann lade dir gut ging ein alter ihr
müsst euch vor die situation vorstellen
wie geil ist das denn
ihr papa sie extrem denke ich okay jetzt
hektisch zwar dass ich gebannt werde vom
server aber dann bin ich die ruhe auch
auf jeden fall da kommt einfach
irgendein anderer hacker und rasiert
euch einfach und was zur hölle ist mit
diesem typen los wenn man sowas sieht
das einzige von zu sagen kann dass ich
ein bisschen die vibrationen
runtersetzen sollte ich hatte vorhin die
wand an
er sprintet seitwärts muss auch sein
gegner
rott als ob der warte lobby schild und
der andere ist der deathmatch arena der
andere wurde einfach von der mep in die
warnow wiegt als ob das habe ich auch
noch nie gesehen hatte das ist dann wohl
die abgefuckt erste runde sg die jemals
gespielt wurde mit ziemlich hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit ersprintet einfach
seitlich de einfach so viele hände
momente der erste usain bolt rennt über
die märkte dann ein zweiter usain bolt
kommt dazu die jagen einander dann usain
bolt mit eisen rüstungsexport mit der
rüstung dann usain bolt mit einer
rüstung wird ins deathmatch teleportiert
sprintet seitwärts und rückwärts also so
wie die ganze jenna und der ist aber
niemand weil der andere einfach in die
wartung bietet abhilfe kann ich habe
keine ahnung mit welchem club man so
etwas bewerkstelligen könnte wenn ihr in
der ahnung hat mit welchem equipment man
sowas hinbekommen kann dass man in eine
andere lobby telefoniert wird
es ist nicht wie kontrollleuchten für
den monitor es ist vielleicht nicht dann
könnt ihr das und eine beschreibung
schreiben dank an alle die diese woche
eingesendet haben und alle die das sehen
wenn ihr wieder hacker seht fleißig
fleißig fleißig aufnehmen auf youtube
hochladen und mir per privater nachricht
den link schicken denn die hacker show
läuft wieder und ich wirklich vorne
dabei sein